[Music]
shonies take all your clothes off and
fold yourself 12 times this is exactly
what i say when i open a fresh package
of origami paper no i'm not sexualizing
the art form but there is something
about
those creases
also leaving your underwear on when
you're clearly told to remove all
clothing dude literally tries to fold
himself 12 times but gets caught up on
the never nude claws i admire you rick
weird time to be feeling admiration for
one's intellect while staring into your
coffee mug's brown eye also fart mug is
adorned with a shony's label and not one
that reads spencer gifts imagine
deciding between master sword morty and
spiked bat morty when throwing star
morty's right freaking there spilling
your breakfast pills and leaving them on
the table especially the orange pink one
those things are like the bacon of the
morning capsule meal industry stop
saying his name he abandoned us i know
i'm not supposed to cry over spilled
milk but that merlot didn't even have a
chance to be sipped slowly after a
snarky one-liner willem dafoe that's the
guy i couldn't think of this morning not
being able to remember finding nemo's
willem dafoe let's go visit some
memories oh any particular ones you want
to see my first boner or should we go
straight to the moment i discovered
interdimensional travel let's go for the
second choice my first boner was at the
front of my seventh grade math class
after solving a difficult problem pretty
sure by the time i was done everyone had
solved for d yeah well
there's no tougher tee than a psychotic
break rick i once watched a lady crush a
six-pack of beer watermelon in a brick
with her on an episode of america's got
talent so i'm inclined to disbelieve
this fact between where you were on 9 11
and your favorite sports blooper frank
is one of the most intelligent creatures
in the history of creatures and his
favorite sports blooper isn't jose
canseco head butting a ball into the
stands for a home run please also how
does this baseball ricochet upwards off
of this nut shot i've got a degree in
testicle physics and that's just not how
it works look at these dead flies maybe
if we arrange them in a certain order it
plays a hologram or it opens a secret
door summer's over here tampering with
evidence in a world where the alien
insect-based galactic empire rules with
an iron fist you'd think this might be a
murder scene a bunch of the szechuan
sauce like as much as you're allowed to
give me in the history of life imitating
art that imitates life there's never
been a bigger fluster cluck than the
rick and morty szechuan sauce wars
here's 15 sins for nostalgia-based
hysteria and one in back because
honestly that's a pretty good sauce but
also the dude can invent
multi-dimensional time portals but can't
recreate a sauce
bug boners bugners bow nooks honestly
i'm surprised with this much arousal the
bug suit's able to contain itself do you
know how many suits or pairs of pants
i've ripped from my bouts of excitement
none because i'm perfectly proportioned
why did they bury this world's rick with
a portal gun in fact why did they bury
this world's rick at all other rick
could have just easily thrown the corpse
into a portal or incinerated or anything
that wouldn't require the manual labor
of digging a hole i don't know yet i'll
make it up as i go the motto from the
rick and morty writers room somehow
makes its way into the episode that's my
sister this used to be my home right
because weird stuff that happens in rick
and morty is brought back and referenced
by the show when it's convenient what is
the matter with you people you're a
bunch of back savages backstab averages
we got you on this one morty
a self-aware elongated and purposely
created fictional decoy no is still a no
yeah that's the three lines of math that
separates my life as a man from my life
as an unfeeling ghost rejoice rick could
be worse i've heard three lines of coke
can get you feeling like an unfeeling
ghost math is a much healthier option
gets me excited at least awesome possum
wait how does this bug know what a
possum is did he study that much about
earth's animal kingdom to know how to
make that clever animal rhyme always
wait for permission i feel like acid
reflux would be a result of the
condition of the body and not the
consciousness and so the insect alien
shouldn't have rick's heartburn once
rick's mind transferred and if you're
telling me that acid reflux becomes a
part of a person's soul then i
hate everything what's the level 9
master access code again nathan phillian
doing a rick sanchez impersonation is
everything i need in my life what a
treasure but also i'm still mad that he
never got to do uncharted and this show
reminded me of that emotion in a
roundabout way so i'm bummed i didn't
get to give that insect a test drive
wait you said you had to take a level 9
dump does that mean this insect species
poos out of their
some things are better off unimagined
d-99 this is the commander-in-chief of
the citadel's militia good uh good
enough
he's a spy blow him up i'm gonna go take
a sh rick may have invented the best
conversation segway ever but i do have
to wonder do all the ricks neglect bowel
movements i can only imagine having the
urge to poop over and over again has to
be a curse now the release of said waste
i could do with that feeling over and
over again plus i'd be able to catch up
on all my philip defranco show in one
day with that much time spent on the
toilet you killed him because you were
jealous of him that's pretty obvious
from the haircut judging someone by
their haircut unless of course we're
talking about billy ray cyrus circuit
1990s or las vegas raiders owner mark
davis then it's totally fair i was just
trying to protect my sister
i wanted you to have a normal life rick
and morty tries to have emotional stakes
in a show where everyone's disposable
and no one's redeemable cliche
[Music]
hold on hold on
there are multiple already broken window
panes for you to jump out of balding
rick smartest mammal in the universe my
ass okay i'm all about ease of access to
go to the bathroom when in an armored
outfit but not protecting your buggy
bull bag you're in the middle of a gun
fight i'd rather get shot in the face
than have a hole in my scrotum now i'm
questioning if the insect who designed
this armored practicality in mind when
creating these do the insects have extra
lungs they breathe through in their nut
sack how much elasticity is in the ball
bag can they be spun around their heads
and thrown at the enemy like some sort
of ball sack bolos to ensnare them i'm
not getting this out of my head for
weeks am i me
american idioms have a very weird
influence on alien culture my dad used
to say he wore the pants in the
household but rarely did i see him with
pants on he was a tighty whities and a
tank top kind of guy so was i really the
man of the house remember when phones
only had one camera and it didn't feel
like you were carrying around the hubble
telescope array yeah good times nancy
says they're drawing and quartering
aliens in the school courtyard and it
technically counts as patriotism
americans co-signing the brutal death
and torture of a culture or species you
don't say nine more seasons until i get
that dipping szechuan sauce spoilers
summer next time we're hiding in a
calorical echo nest can you do me a
favor and turn your ringer off despite
what the subtitles say it's still not
entirely clear what's being dealt with
here was it a clerkian echo that had a
nest or was it a calorican that had an
echo nest how am i supposed to update
the fan wiki now dan that's because
losers look stuff up darn right pink
shirt girl in this episode of this
television show darn right to live is to
risk it all otherwise you're just an
inert chunk of randomly assembled
molecules drifting wherever the universe
blows you show makes us question whether
or not this statement was actually
profound or just a setup to burn jerry
cool just stay in the driveway the
killbots are live and i took you off the
white list good thing you just randomly
stopped right before walking into the
garage then or bad thing yeah let's go
with bad thing back in the very first
episode of rick and morty tv since we
made a joke about this towing company
and finished by saying that toes don't
bend like that we were then inundated in
the comments with people saying that
their toes do in fact bend like that and
i say [ __ ] i'm giving 10 sins to you
toe scam liars seriously if you can
extend your big toe and still fully flex
all four of your other toes to where the
pads of the toe are touching the bottom
of your foot i'll give 20 cents back in
the next rick and morty episode we send
and name drop you for it just send the
proof to picks or it didn't happen at
cinemasins.com for verification and
absolutely not because i want to look at
pictures of strangers feet as far as you
know half open boxes in the mattress
leaning up against the side secured only
by this tall and unstable lamp the sin
is jerry loading his truck like a jerry
insults can someone help me understand
if butts or faces and faces or butts in
this world then what part of the butt is
buttface morty watching the face butt
porn with and what orifice on the face
butt do buttfaces use to you know what i
just decided i don't want to know any of
this ding it quickly please this episode
is not titled mad rick mortyroad the
exploding war boy on the back of their
vehicle has little to no impact on them
or the car proving that even a show with
an established plot device for replacing
main characters can also be shameless in
its use of plot armor i [ __ ] love
post-apocalyptic versions of art people
that believe in climate change but still
don't give a sh this stuff's so powerful
morty it makes isotope 465 look like
isotope 317. this techno babble is so
star trek tng it makes doctor who look
like sliders your blood will be my
lotion blood would be a terrible ocean
dries up almost immediately and then you
walk around smelling like iron and
looking like a giant scab this creature
with a horizontal hydraulic denture
mouth harmonica nose face speaks lies is
it really easier to eat human flesh and
to just tell me why we're still here
no
[Laughter]
no matter how many times you watch these
episodes there's always that one joke
that hits hard and this is the one that
did it for me uh you mean the blood dome
save it for the semantics dome e.b white
i'm this close to giving another cent
off for yet another hilarious bit but
then i realized that calling the blood
dome the thunderdome isn't just a
semantic difference blood is very
different than thunder although i do
hide under the covers the moment i
experience either of them this device
extracts and redistributes muscle memory
this macguffin is fired so ungracefully
up the ass of this episode i have to
give it two sins even though its
penetration in the end will be quite
enjoyable letting this bicep meet rot in
the heat and some chose to huddle near
the boomy holes calling it your boomy
hole and letting someone huddle near it
for the vert vertis on billy boards did
the boomy booms blow up all your wordy
word books summer would be furiosa tv
sins nipple suspenders as a fashion
statement super cool nipple suspenders
as your chosen blood dome uniform
[ __ ] liability man good thing the
lady in the water arm chose this moment
to stop destroying everything in its
vicinity the second summer showed up huh
this neck keeps pulsing more blood out
of it and honestly sometimes i think the
show forgets that disgusting things can
be distracting things and if they're not
careful i might not be paying close
enough attention to catch the next fart
joke
we'll be right back aside from the usual
nonsense fourth wall breaking this
should also be sent for how it allows
the show to fast forward through how
rick got out of this situation why
summer sided with the death stalkers and
if morty's monster arm got in some quick
dealt work before it suddenly decided to
drive him out here chopping wood
one-handed wait chopping wood
left-handed
now i'm gonna whip you narrating your
whipping is only acceptable if a problem
comes along and you whip it good what
about the weird guys on leashes then
they're more like interns this [ __ ]
claims to have little memory of the
before four times so this means that
internships as a concept have survived
the apocalypse actually it makes perfect
sense that something is soulless and
evil would survive the end of the world
but still [ __ ] internships can i
see
no one has seen my true face and lived
scene does not contain a baby yoda a
metal bucket is on a certain level a
kind of mustache in that it's a specific
facial accessory a mustache is not just
a facial accessory it's a growing and
ever-changing part of you that requires
care and nurturing so it can one day
become a full and prominent statement of
your desire to never drink milk in
public ever again the thing i find most
disconcerting about this whole scene is
how all of them just sit there
conversing with an entire meatball on
their fork i have so many questions like
aren't you worried about the sauce
dripping all over the place as you
gesture are you planning on eating the
entire meatball in one bite are you not
including any spaghetti with the
meatball they are meant to be eaten
together you savages and that's before
we even get to your serving sizes that
plate of spaghetti is as big as your
head that's probably 3 000 calories
worth of spaghetti there and i'm not
even counting the pureed egg yolk drink
you've included dial it back summer by
15 and increase dynamic movement by
three no matter how many times this show
tries to explain away beth being
oblivious to all things rick because of
the issues with their relationship she
has also been established to be a very
smart person only takes a moderately
smart person like myself to see through
this robotic family ruse plus dynamic
movement adjustments are always done in
increments of five otherwise what's the
point you millennials
generationalizations please slavery was
a family business that's his business
the flashback we saw earlier was of his
men murdering the entire village the
writers think someone could be this bad
at business and also have a taint washer
uh armothy can i steal you for a second
armothy armothy what about arm and fight
or sleeve jobs i mean hand squish em
anderson was right there maybe the
lesson we've learned is that i don't get
to do this with rick and morty so skip
i did all this in three weeks i mean my
neighbor started putting up a fence in
his backyard three months ago and he's
still not done part of the scene is
probably on my lazy neighbor
bruce but this is still a lot of
infrastructure for 21 days we were
monsters we didn't care about anything i
still don't yeah except i'm the only one
in this entire world that's still
committed to that oh
ding ding ding ding ding ding three sins
oh i get it you want me to send the
marriage kills romance and results in
conflict cliche fair enough here's your
ding ding ding no union built on running
from your problems last more than five
years seven tops usa deniers
[Music]
no unless my suffering is your
nourishment tv sins
i turned myself into a pickle morty with
the garage door open i mean it's
possible rick couldn't care less if
people know he's a mad scientist but i
usually like a little privacy when i'm
transforming my pickle i'm pickle rick
roll dill marshalls it's probably sin
enough that this intro scene doesn't
have an episode yet but i'm just
confused why each butt cheek would have
a separate face when the face is the
entire butt shouldn't the butt then be
the entire face and wouldn't this make
the mouth the oh god i've gone too far
also it's official rick and morty needs
to do a whole episode including all the
stuff they didn't do from the intros and
turn it into one episode they're good at
off-the-wall concepts so time to make it
happen [ __ ] stop digging for hidden
layers and just be impressed rick and
morty fans in our comments section did
you do this on purpose to get out of
family counseling he did and it really
makes me wonder why he didn't do
something a lot less convoluted seems
like he could have simply faked being
sick or made himself sick for real and
had an antidote hidden somewhere or
thousands of other things he could have
done to get out of therapy we're going
to get one of the most famous rick and
morty episodes out of it but while it's
hard to complain it's not hard to sin
hey rick why is there a syringe of
mysterious fluid hanging directly over
you morty's got a point here why would
rick set up some sort of rube goldberg
and syringe solution in full view of
everyone i would think someone smart
enough to become an actual pickle would
also be smart enough to hide whatever
creative way they've found to not be a
pickle anymore for instance conjuring a
me seeks and asking them to hide until
everyone leaves and then administer the
antidote for one possible solution beth
conveniently leaves the garage door open
so the pickle rick can get into his
adventure
[Music]
this goes on for some time it was a
bright ass sunny day with no cloud in
sight then the clouds with the flooding
rain came out of nowhere to bale rick
out i'm pretty sure it only rains long
enough for rick to get to the next phase
of the story making this the biggest
deus ex market of rain since noah when
god killed all of noah's ark nemesis
also floods don't happen this fast and
unless the water is coming directly from
the garage this driveway wouldn't
accumulate water at any depth at all
pickle rick is apparently holding his
breath underwater so can we talk
anatomical morphing does this mean this
pickle has respiratory circulatory and
neurological systems and if so isn't it
more of a pickle-shaped human than an
actual human turned into a pickle
[Music]
yes
how did he say yes so clearly if he's
tonguing a roach's brain nonstop to make
it move also most scientists think that
arthropods actually have a distributed
intelligence which means their motion is
controlled at multiple points of the
body meaning this cerebral english
shouldn't really be doing all that much
at all it's nobody's choice to be here
you knobs the family was told to get
counseling by your principle sounds like
the principal was a co-writer on this
script considering the unusual requests
for the entire family to get counseling
even though it's not the family that was
huffing pottery glaze in the art room as
far as my research shows pottery glaze
does not contain any brain altering
substances oh you sweet summer child how
long have you all been eating poop yeah
i bet when you have fond memories of the
pickle rick episode you don't remember
the morty dusk peeing incident or the
teacher that eats poop do you this rat
trap includes a weight wall screws and
bolts and a tied off rubber band secured
at twice a pickle's height how the hell
could rick build this at his current
pickle size and with a distinct lack of
opposable thumps this rick builds
complex machinery quickly with no hands
or tools it's going to be a common thing
isn't it fine let's add five sins for
this plot forwarding nonsense and move
on good thing the city installed these
sewer covers to give way with such great
sense of dramatic timing i know this is
one of those things where you're not
supposed to think very deeply into it
and just accept that rick who is a
pickle screwed rat arms and legs onto
himself and now has the agility of tony
jaw as he rampages through this rat
horde but if rat anatomy is this amazing
i find it hard to believe they wouldn't
rule the world or at the very least have
complete control of the new york city
subways also don't get me wrong going
all john rick chapter 3 picklebellum on
these rats is pure amazingness but
unless he's broken the law of
conservation of mass him making this
machine appear complete with seemingly
unlimited ammo out of absolutely nothing
can suck my gherkin well dr wong by the
way racist name calling things racist
that aren't even racist at all do you
have any self-awareness god you were
special the rats now they're dead i
guess it was me you should have
impressed i feel like somewhere this
episode should get a sin off for its
goofy premise paying off and i'll do it
here i mean to be a nitpicky bastard but
what the [ __ ] is up with all these vents
in this hallway and room 280 is directly
across the hallway from room 290. who in
the toilet is this
did rick get this deep into the middle
of nowhere from that sewer he was in hi
um can you
please let me out can't rick just find a
way out on his own he's been using the
vents to get around and he has more
resources than when he was down in the
sewers and down there he could build a
jet pack and a whole complicated rat
part assembly machine some of my men are
calling you solenya the pickle man an
old wives tale he crawls from bowls of
cold soup to steal the dreams of
wasteful children this old wives tale is
about as stupid as the first wives club
a pickle has some sort of waste not want
not boogeyman i know russia's [ __ ] up
guys but it can be way more creative and
[ __ ] up than that this russian
syndicate must shop for office supplies
at the same company as john wick and
ledger's joker because these industrial
strength pencils are somehow nailing
someone to a wall and impaling entire
human shoulders my pencil breaks when i
press too hard while dotting the eye and
kendrick with a little heart what do you
think is in the syringe bath you're the
one that cost 200 an hour you tell me
okay so this mandatory counseling costs
200
i can barely even see the family
agreeing to this counseling much less
paying 200 an hour oh my god oh
there's pictures of people eating poop
in there the alternate title of this
episode was clearly fecal rick as little
that's left of these desks i'm
questioning their ability to support a
full van dam in their current condition
how is rick flying this chopper without
being able to reach the anti-torque
pedal and other important helicoptery
things
what is this some kind of suicide squad
i have no doubt that you would be bored
senseless by therapy the same way i'm
bored when i brush my teeth and wipe my
ass who has ever been wiping their ass
and said to themselves god damn this is
boring it's not like it's supposed to be
fun feels like this is just another way
for the episode to wallow again she
huffed enamel and we never even talked
about it uh yeah he did it's what led to
summer saying i am mad that i can't huff
enamel without people assuming it's
because my family sucks saying she'd
prefer people to just think she likes to
get high it was discussed
a stringed instrument would be
completely muted by crushed corpses
attached to its strings even in the key
of b flat now
for the e splat
jaguar is jaguar um gonna untie rick and
morty don't let any of those things get
away morty and be sure to keep the
garage door open while these things
scurry about that seems to propel a lot
of our plots also is this a garden hose
hanging on the side of the smith house
that thing is huge that is the girthiest
yard hose ever to hose a yard can we
call it dirt diggler i morty smith
invoke my right to choose one in every
10 rick and morty adventures so it's
true rick and morty have adventures that
are not televised so it's possible we
haven't seen other adventures chosen by
morning but the episode me seeks and
destroys seemingly established that
morty would choose at least one
adventure in every 10 episode season
when morty angled to be in charge of
every third adventure and rick casually
rebutted him off with every tenth this
self-aware show was surely referring to
the number of episodes in a season i
think they just forgot this was a thing
until now this time travel box hasn't
paid off and i'm calling it it's been
long enough i want some time travel
shenanigans damn it this container has
been teasing me since episode one and my
flux is at full capacitor they did all
vindicators without us a bunch of them
got killed too so morty is an unabashed
vindicators fan and while it makes sense
that they would do an adventure without
rick and morty it seems like he would
have figured that out already since he's
such a huge fan of eminem wouldn't he
have various news feeds set up to follow
whatever the vindicators were doing even
when they weren't assembled yikes yeah
things did feel less diverse in there
sure there's a white guy but there's
also a woman who is apparently a solar
system a person made of ants a robot
crocodile and a ghost train conductor of
color what the hell is rick even talking
about i'll buy that supernova and vance
can fly down from the jet and i guess
maybe million ants can somehow float
down with morty and toe but how do allen
rails and crocubot even come close to
surviving the impact of that height are
you all right yes i only lost 400 ants
million ants is made up of a million
ants this many bullet holes would have
caused the slaughter of well into the
tens of thousands my queen is laying
more
i am back to one million ants literal
ant-man could have had any kind of
biology and it would make sense i
suppose i mean this guy is made up of
ants but don't know ants have to go
through the larvae and pupae stages
before developing into full-blown ants
this whole process lasts a month at
least so even if your queen could
somehow spit them out that fast your
chronology needs some more geez
supernova i mean there's unrealistic
body image and then there is a toilet
paper roll balancing two cantaloupes
while sitting on top of the great
pumpkin is your superpower transmitting
body dysmorphia we're taking fire from
an automated turret can you bring it
offline seems like they wouldn't need
rick to do this since many of the
superheroes have powers that could
easily destroy the turret on their own
but this episode is a parody of
superhero movies so maybe that's the
point i'm sending it anyway because i
won't feel right in the morning if i
don't okay so the turrets shoot the
decoy and it absorbs the bullets but why
do they stop shooting once the decoy
goes back into the box these guns
clearly have more bullets left because
they end up blowing themselves up after
rick's hilariously complicated device
locks them down do it in three minutes
or you'll all die so what point does
rick transition from hilarious
nihilistic [ __ ] to legitimate
supervillain has he always been the
villain of the show look that's fine if
that's the case i'm just saying at some
point we need some sort of moral
foundation here right this is triggering
me i need space does anyone even want to
just glance at the board and maybe just
do the easy matching game i'm as
stubborn and prideful as the next guy
but if my life's on the line i'm at
least gonna check out the difficulty
level before i get all flustered look i
know the drunk rick set all this up and
all of this is surprising to him too but
sober rick doesn't care one bit about
these [ __ ] so why is he all
horrified about fans the rick we know
and love would be stoic about this and
be ready with a sarcastic quip give me
one reason why i shouldn't crush your
windpipe because my epidermis is laced
with the nanofiber defense mesh okay
that's awesome but when he grabbed your
neck your eyeball went to bloodshot
which means your defense mesh wasn't
working when he first grabbed you it
appears to only exist for this joke of
course we're going to keep our eye on
that clock and now it appears to be
under a minute even though only one
minute has passed since the three
minutes started this is like the friends
apartment quiz all over again except
rick's more likeable than ross but they
don't
pick the location you'll
you'll never hear them even mention oh i
know this dude this game doesn't even
have a timer why the rush even drunk
pickled rick is a super genius but he's
just one super genius right how does one
person build this entire fully automated
giant instructional screen and an
interactive holographic display in one
drunken knight drunk version of me is
probably so supportive of israel he
wants what's best for it and hey man i'm
not touching this that's a funny reply
but does million ants know the
geopolitical complexity of issues
concerning israel to the point that he
knows it's a touchy subject let's say
you have to hit five three-pointers in
five minutes or i don't know the whole
place is all planet will get blown up
with a neutrino bomb rick clearly
recorded his audio first making it up as
he went and then had to enact his
ramblings into the real world which is
kind of brilliant considering that's
basically how this show seems to be
created so this is either a sin for rick
standing in as the proxy for the
writer's laziness or a sin for being
brilliant enough to get away with it
either way oh disarm the drunkenly
improvised neutrino bomb morty how many
of these too many rick too many okay so
he's disarmed a few of these bombs but
why the hell is he all the sudden going
full heart locker when we all know
non-drunk rick is the one that will
eventually take care of this is there
something set up on this basketball
court that detects the distance from
which these guys shoot the basket
because it seems like they could just
shoot layups and everything rigged up
here wouldn't know the difference i mean
if it allows supernova to cheat the
three-pointers like this then there's
nothing stopping them from taking the
easiest shot possible because when
you're an [ __ ] it doesn't matter how
right you are nobody wants to give you
the satisfaction thing overheard at tv
sims team building retreat somehow makes
it into a rick and morty script wouldn't
rick's nano fiber defense mesh easily be
able to break these handcuffs so morty
gets on the platform and it works but we
find out that drunk rick was thinking of
noob noob as the answer to this question
and while this game might just be total
bull and that's exactly the point of it
all this whole thing is so detailed
you'd think if drunk rick was really
thinking about noob new he'd have made
sure the platform required noob new
every single puzzle rick set up was
accompanied by a video and every single
one of these recordings took place in
his garage and while he may not have had
every game plan he clearly had the last
game plan because he had already cut out
the rainbow background for the last
video message but that last one was
recorded somewhere in the cave they're
currently in so why did he wait to do
this one here when he did all the other
videos in his garage you were always the
romantic which is why you can't leave
either
so supernova is a full-blown psychopath
now just like that was there any sign of
this over her years of service this is a
sin for the vindicator's hr department
if nothing else i'm going to enjoy this
and let's give a huge thanks to rick
sanchez wouldn't all the people up here
have seen supernova doing all the evil
she did including killing million ants
while they took the ride on the elevator
you mean nobody was looking down during
that whole thing and what about the
superheroes nobody looked up and saw
tons of people up there having a party
and for booking one of the hottest
talents out there logics i mean there's
logic problems and then there's logic
problems apparently this episode has
both does jerry not grow mustache
stubble also wearing tighty off-whities
the show's hitting the sad sac jerry
punching back hard in this opening even
insinuating he flosses while on the
toilet but in what world does someone
with jerry's personality traits even
floss at all oh i couldn't give a [ __ ]
about washing my undies in the sink but
gotta take care of my teeth tweeners
rick and jerry episode breaking the
fourth wall to advertise your episode
shortcomings oversaturating the plumbus
market what did you think it was an
execution jeez you really do need a win
is it really that far-fetched though the
truth is the rick we've been shown in
this show is probably more likely to
execute jerry or manufacture a new one
entirely rather than waste his time
trying to give him a win this seems kind
of fancy jerry for all you know this is
the equivalent of an alien truck stop
you have no frame of reference rick
would be a master convincer at tv sins
the resort's covered in an immortality
field you can't die here that's the
gimmick i have questions and thoughts of
plenty about the functionality
practicality and sustainability of an
immortality field far too many to
contain in the parameters of this one
sin so i'm going to sprinkle them in
whenever i feel there's a lull in the
cinnable but first off both rick and his
buddy seem to be in pain when they're
harpooned and glassed immortality should
really not be so appealing when you can
still feel the pain of death rich
a-holes are rich a-holes they all pay
top dollar to come here and enjoy a
consequence-free vacation stealing your
idea from westworld the book or the old
movie but not the new show which came
out later so then we'd send that for
stealing from this this job's
complicated mom do you think i'm hot
this entire bee plot is dangerously
skippable so i'll use it instead to
untable my immortality field doctoral
thesis next up is the fact that this
isn't technically an immortality field
it's a resurrection and regeneration
field an immortality field would prevent
death from occurring in the first place
and allow you to survive your injuries
regardless of severity which would make
this a [ __ ] horror escape of a resort
where you never die but have to
continuously feel the pain of any injury
or mishap that befalls you is that a
hoof collage
it's perfectly legal if that's what
you're wondering nope i was just
wondering why you're leaving your wine
glass directly under the disembodied
hoove sculpture do you want hoof and
mouth disease because this may or may
not be how you get hoof and mouth
disease or could it be her massive
stripper trees in my
limited amount of research i can confirm
there is no specific shape or size of tv
required to be a stripper yeah of course
he likes it look at him [ __ ] got
two heads and three trunks that's by
cranial try proboscis between the first
whirly and the third durley the ride
dips just outside the immortality field
well that's just terrible theme park
design i don't want to judge an alien
race by its appearance but i do want to
know more about the genetic quirks of
this species for example why does this
individual have nipples when the others
do not and why do they have one bubble
gum stalk and yet our bigger friend here
has two and why are they bumpy when the
smaller chaps are perfectly smooth you
can't give me another new alien race
without the proper information to fill
out my rick and morty decks if she is
this big and the machine's still running
how is she a alive and b not immediately
popping morty like a tomato sauce
balloon the second he tries to squeeze
through there there are some major
issues between you and beth that have
been there since you guys met this is
what apparently tips jerry over the edge
into patricide in law this an insightful
statement that's likely based on truth
as opposed to one of the many careless
or hateful things that rick has done
what's worse is that the show never has
a problem making rick out to be the
[ __ ] so why not use this as an
opportunity to show him really
tormenting jerry and jerry finally
breaking what else could reverse
possibly mean in fairness to beth this
is a terrible setting description this
setting should have clearly been called
inside out which still would be
incorrect considering basically all that
happens is the skin inverts but somehow
leaves the eyes and mouth intact man
this is gonna be awesome rick doesn't
find it at all suspicious that despite
the huge line of people waiting behind
him this card is allowed to leave
completely empty other than the two
clearly assassinate looking assassins in
the back that are inexplicably being
allowed to stay on despite having
already partaken in the coaster also how
did the assassins know that this cart
was the card that rick and jerry were
gonna be on and how could they guarantee
that rick and jerry were going to be at
the front of the line
did jerry just lift up the lap bar
mid-ride that should not be possible i
know this is an animated show but i've
had literal names about this exact
scenario and i need to know that this
should not be possible the assassin
inexplicably waits until rick and jerry
have almost re-entered the resurrection
and restoration field i don't even think
they have a line of sight now instead of
activating a bomb i just assume this
button was some sort of quick release
mechanism for rick's lab coat and what's
concerning about this is i didn't even
question how ineffective and ridiculous
that would be my brain just said yeah
that tracks and i am not okay with how
this show is reshaping my logic center
look i've never managed a resort with a
resurrection and restoration field but
if i did i don't think i'd put the power
source to said field where it was so
open to being damaged i mean look at all
this rock why not bury that way
underground rick and jerry survive this
and you might think that's silly but the
whole episode is about a place with a
resurrection and restoration field and
when you're going to have your character
survive a direct collision with a
mountain and a rocketing wheel of death
your supposed immortality field becomes
about as important as the lowest button
on a button-down shirt i mean it's there
for a purpose but does it really change
much who do you think had more taken
from them when you shot 20 cc's of
liquid dream killer into my daughter
i [ __ ] love the writers of this show
she was rick's daughter jerry she had
options
the monster stopped eating him for a
second to pile on and say oof yeah yeah
two sin removals in a row because the
random forest monster said
i mean balls hilarious i get it but he
could just duck down on the pouch a bit
right also the creature that evolved to
carry its young within punching distance
of its gonads would like a quick
conversation with darwin please kissing
rick's ass isn't gonna help keep him
around mom but it will help you lose
everyone else chapter 47 on my thesis
challenging the r r resort a title that
the owners really dropped the ball on by
not using now that i think about it is
wondering if laws regarding murder and
assault don't apply here i mean you're
still going through the mental and
physical trauma of being attacked and
assaulted so are there just no
repercussions because there's no lasting
physical damage like i lost summer hey
you haven't lost her yet no i definitely
did she's gone there is not a chance
summer would have been able to sneak
away she's too big to miss would shake
the ground when she walked and would be
reigning garage debris it's a synaptic
dampener that blocks violent tendencies
and controversial thought i want cookies
and a 90-minute cut of avatar this show
cuts so deep i [ __ ] love it but
unfortunately i'm dangerously close to
maxing out my sin removals for the
season so i'll just have to send the
cookie monster shade instead wait i know
where she is of course you do how else
would we wrap up two story lines in the
next five minutes ethan and summer were
supposed to go camping and then he
dumped summer the next book in my r r
field series will be dedicated to
organized crime why isn't this resort
being overrun with space mobsters and
criminals that can either use it as a
place to torture their enemies or as a
hideout where they can't be hurt by the
authorities using it as a theme park is
wildly undervaluing its potential live
out the rest of your days in denial of
your vagina fantasies it was a one-time
thought that everyone has i mean other
than the people that already have a
vagina right rick and morty episode
steals the best scene from everything
everywhere all at once and the dumbest
scene from dr strange ii five years
before either of them came out and don't
act like that is impossible in a show
like this oh god i feel like our souls
were united and we're all one with
eternity still a better explanation than
anything i've heard defending the ending
of interstellar
and the final series of volumes will be
spent positing that the r resort should
be swamped by the entire damn universe
this is a place where you not only can't
be permanently killed but it reverses
the thing that killed you so anyone with
a spaceship and a terminal illness can
come here die and be cured of anything
that was killing them this resort should
be the seat of power for the entire damn
multiverse i know giant inside out kaigu
versions of summer and beth are in this
scene but the real monster here is morty
who uses his bare thumb to pat down this
melted marshmallow directly touching the
marshmalto is a surefire way to ruin any
shot you have at not sticking directly
to everything you come in contact with
for the rest of the evening show takes
21 minutes and 13 seconds to actually
rick and morty i heard you broke up with
brad who are you gonna date now that you
can date anyone why is this an immediate
question to ask someone that just broke
up i understand that they're keenly
curious about body stuff as evidenced in
the following line penis in the foreskin
kind of luck so yeah go figure out what
you enjoy i guess but can we just let
people take a longer than 12 second
break between the end of one
relationship and questions about the
next you can be single is what i'm
saying this highly questionable school
art that is inspiring a love of
microscopes trophies open flames hookah
and magnetic floating chalices i'm
confused about my career path by simply
glancing at it let's go in and out 20
minutes adventure title of my
over-ambitious sex tape in this shot the
fleet isn't concentrating their
firepower on one location but when we
zoom in the firepower seems to be aimed
at this vulva's mass don't get me wrong
one should always concentrate on the
vulva's mass but be consistent why is
there skin flapping around as the wind
is pushing it back from the ship's
trajectory i get the g-forces do crazy
things to your face but for this amount
of gum flappage surely they'd have to be
taking some bizarre route out of here
and not the straight line that we see in
this shot
i can't do this anymore audio from the
tv since writer's room after sending
game of thrones final season somehow
makes it into the episode this was
insane that was pure luck i was not in
control of that situation at all
followed by jeremy and chris's reaction
to the birth of cinemasins also making
its way into a rick and morty episode
not closing all of your eyes when
receiving a massage you were right best
day spa in the galaxy enjoying whatever
this is with your grandfather these
things are just doing what they do in
the wild they love swallowing stressed
out creatures for 20 minutes and then
puking them up i think cats feel this
way about birds like it's their
responsibility to end their stressful
birdie lives consume them and then vomit
them on my pillow at 3am as if it does
anyone a favor so this sentence for the
unexpected visual memory barrage of my
long gone audubon obsessed cat oliver
oliver my whole body's like a baby's ass
diapered and rashy that makes no sense
try swallowing the giant ball of snot
that's dangling around in the back of
your throat it's disgusting says the man
who for 90 of his day has more bodily
fluids on his face than jabba the hutt's
gynecologist it's nice of you to let me
off the hook it's still unacceptable
behavior and i do regret it rick is
being extra nice because he's had all of
his toxins removed but that would seem
to overlook that some of the most toxic
people you will ever meet will carry
themselves with a kind word and a smile
yeah take that you came here for sex
tape jokes and left with life facts
suckers i'm real proud to be your
grandpa morty i guess this is on me for
enjoying this wholesome moment while
also realizing that the toxic elements
of rick and morty are ripped from their
consciousness do do i prefer this show
am i a sap trained by television to feel
better when everyone gets along like
puppets while you were flapping your
parasitic turd holster not specifying
what the turd holster is precisely so
i'm now unsure how to use it in
situations requiring insult slinging i
discovered the toxic equivalent of
electricity morty
i love the idea that there's a toxic
version of electricity even if it
doesn't make any sense i mean would
lightning just deliberately pick out the
nicest people to strike would a power
surge wait until you've nearly finished
a big project to short out your computer
and then do exactly the same thing to
your brand new computer just the [ __ ]
with you wait toxic electricity may
already be a thing now who can tell me
the common denominator of these two
fractions
you don't know or you're just bored
false dichotomies with the kids clothing
variety as your only clue you will never
discover the mystery of the current
weather pattern in the neighborhood if
we're all bored over here wouldn't the
common denominator be you we learned
that it's only the character traits the
individual believes are toxic that have
been removed but i still struggle to
believe that morty doesn't think being a
back-talking smartass to his teacher
doesn't fall into the realm of toxicity
i do however know that i have a pretty
bad case of haven't taken you to dinner
itis this works oh sh the item on the
wall wasn't art at all it was an actual
trophy case well in that case i will
remove a sin because i called it art and
then madison back because it looks like
the rest of the trophy case is further
down the hallway but we saw much more of
it from a different angle earlier i
think i know what to do morty holy sh
what was the foam made out of that it
made it so easy for morty to snap it in
half oh
i'll have a water but but you already
have wine so wouldn't the drink order
have already been taken or is that the
previous table's wine but why is there
wine at the empty tables what is this
restaurant look this is rick and morty
land so i'm gonna gloss over the fact
that these two 14 year olds are having a
first date at this fancy restaurant
instead of a [ __ ] arcade or something
but i refuse to believe that this
teenager would leave the house with
little to no battery on their phone that
is a step too far people hey rick are
you familiar with benoit technology the
[ __ ] behind rick and morty continue
to make me drop the ball when it comes
to resisting the urge to fall into the
annals of the internet just for the sake
of making sure i understand the whole
joke they're making
they're all the bad parts of us which by
the way includes our dishonesty but
dishonesty can have positive uses though
an abundance of honesty can lead to
feeling like you have to fill in the
comment sections of the internet with
all the reasons you hate something
instead of letting people enjoy the
things they love you know just as a
totally random example no
is it wrong if i think this is kind of
hot watching an elder person force a
younger person to toxify themselves in a
garage experiment has rick and morty
asked us to contemplate morals a bit too
far this time
probably did i ask for this huh did i
assessing threat to groin point uses a
defensive groin laser if it only deploys
after multiple hits to the vegetables
have been received
look either this door frame is made of
cardboard or rick's body is made of
titanium and yes in this world either
could be true but if i stop sending
stuff because it could be true these
rick and morty videos would be about
five seconds long carpet's so weak at
tears by hand or hands so strongly tear
carpet either way it's a sin taping the
horse head to the exterior of the frame
rather than opening up the frame to
subtly attach it to the photo directly
it's pretty disgusting so you'll have to
believe me when i say they forgot to put
rick's dismembered and eviscerated body
in this panel the monster's tripping a
spine tube thing out of the center of
the floor with no rick and then suddenly
there's a rick
the random bowl of fruit on the bottom
of the table survives this what did the
booger version of you mean when he said
he was going to make the whole world
toxic i'm sure he just left that as a
clue so rick would know where to find
him once he figures out how to recombine
them both into one being villains are
super helpful like that it must be by
the individual's own definition of
toxicity the best thing about this
episode is that it doesn't just assume
that all's well once the things that you
believe are toxic about you have been
removed we can all be toxic in ways that
we're totally unaware of and it all
comes down to perspective damn you rick
and morty for once again having more
self-awareness and insight than any
cartoon about a belching scientist has
any right to be this moon tower morty is
the perfect heightened metallic
composition for the amplification of
beaming of toxic energies convenient
tower fitting the exact requirements of
the villain's plan is very convenient
kids this stock is a beautiful redhead
recently single not looking to date but
ready to fall in love creators of the
show went to the extra effort of
animating this apple in case this jordan
belmort impression didn't quite hit all
the [ __ ] notes on its own is this
organic
yes proclaiming the organicness of your
food is pointless but it isn't morty
chopping this carrot while neither
moving the knife onto the carrot or the
carrot into the knife levels of
pointless hey did you ever want to hold
the terry fold thinking that playing a
whimsical song will make me hang around
for the entirety of the cr wait what the
hell is a terry fold why does it make me
think of dinosaurs is this like a sexy
dinosaur song how did dinosaurs have sex
i suppose carefully is the obvious
answer wait is that the end of the
credits damn it all right morty you
ready for our adventure to the lost city
of atlantis rick and morty not being
complete [ __ ] to each other is a
pretty clear indicator that we won't be
going to atlantis and i get that's the
point of the episode but it doesn't make
me any less upset that the episode does
not contain an adventure to the lost
city of atlantis also we're three
seasons in and still no one's picked up
this [ __ ] sock we're going from
reality to reality asking rix to
contribute charity canvassing canvassing
hey the brits and the aussies went with
charity muggers and then a shortened
version of that so now there's been bad
word choices on three continents you're
pitching the policeman's ball to a black
teenager here the smartest man in the
universe being aware of the complex and
difficult relationship racial and ethnic
minorities have with the police but
choosing to use the topic as fodder for
his jokes as opposed to actually doing
something about it you don't have to be
a dick i think you know that's not true
when rick stop being polite and start
getting real we wouldn't dare play the
music but the sin as always is joe walsh
eating sardines while driving or pretty
much ever also drinking and driving
citadel morning news news about the
citadel in the morning pretty
self-explanatory when you over explain
things to the different versions of
yourself as if you're the [ __ ] and
before you say what about the mortys you
and i both know they'll never stop
playing with their remote long enough to
watch the news 60 iterations off the
central finite curve there's a rick that
works more with wood than polarity
plating the subtitles on my version say
this narrator sam elliott when it's
actually jeff b davis doing an
impression of sam elliott now whether
that's a mistake or a joke i'm giving it
a sin for making me take the time to
figure it out but also jeff p davis
absolutely nails this sam elliott
impression and the chemical that makes
his brain secrete goes into every simple
rick simple wafers wafer cookie brain
secretion wafer cookies are my least
favorite secretion way for cookies come
home to the impossible flavor of your
own completion tagline of my sex tape
the arrow on that this guy needs a
plumbus sign is not making it clear as
to exactly who needs the plumbus i love
being your new farty kids having an
entire factory that only makes wafer
cookies sure a factory could put out
just one product but [ __ ] wafer
cookies how is there a big enough market
for those k-83 affectionately known as
cool rick k83 doesn't pronounce his name
cool herrick just four normal mortys
normal put it in your blog shop owner
morty is suddenly clever enough to make
this comeback when a moment ago he
wasn't clever enough to give training
day rick and morty any information about
the robbery beyond saying they looked
like mortys the morty town locos making
your gang name sound hispanic by adding
the word logos to it is like the social
science equivalent of adding the word
quantum to things to make them more
sciency more lasers agreed how would you
solve the citadel's financial crisis for
a show is consistently outside the box
as this one is surprising they went with
a boilerplate financial crisis as a
problem facing the citadel i mean at
least give us a financial time crisis
can we fact check this please juggling
would have been enough but this one's
for attempting to fact check a juggling
metaphor when they dismissed class
everyone but these four just walked out
of the room and presumably out of the
building using the front door so why
couldn't these four do the same i see it
in our factories where ricks work for a
fraction of their boss's salary even
though they're identical and have the
same iq if they all have the same iq
then why aren't there robot servants
doing all the work and thousands of
ricks just sitting around drinking
margaritas shoneys what else would i
send here everything else about this
scene is perfectly normal this screen in
the back shows all the rick's running
for office and their percentage in the
polls which equals 100 but where's the
morty date in his percentage even if he
has zero percent at this point he should
still be on this screen since he was
taking part in the debate i believe the
sin here is recrimination you're gonna
lick my balls or what
grandson you keep me peeling squab
squams and slipping nib nibs i'll lick
whatever ain't nailed down well there's
just a lot of here i'm just gonna ignore
for my own sanity and move straight to
sitting rick for licks crimination
against things that are nailed down
bandaging your wound on the outside of
your
clothes hey y'all get the hell away from
my damn mega fruit mega fruit seeds
didn't go up a button this episode i bet
the wishing portal leads to a reality
where they're we're all where it's a
bunch of french toast with boobies does
the french toast have boobies or are the
boobies on the side i need to know slick
why do you have to be so dramatic
episode has a slick morty but no slick
rick i thought i was left-handed morty
then you should use your left hand to
eat more vegetables lizard morty would
be tv sins morty at well tv sins
associating food with a hard rick is not
a health code violation in this scene
one dance for ten two for 25. for a
moment i was worried about shaming
autosexuality here but the longer i
spend with this scene the more certain i
become that this is something else
entirely oh i want to be a regular kid i
want to go to school and throw balls
around and masturbate joe wants me to
believe those last two aren't one in the
same we got your portal gun after he
drops the shield they make a little baby
portal to give him the gun so while he
is distracted and the shield was still
down couldn't they have opened multiple
portals in the flavor core and
surrounded him a portal to the blender
dimension the one-line pitch responsible
for event horizon the factory made
cookies
flavored them with lies splenda you have
to give up something really important
for me that's my panini maker i wish for
a million sandwiches
and yes i see the irony not requesting
these sandwiches at a specific interval
so they don't arrive all at once and
spoil i wish anything about this life
would change the show does the wildest
most nonsensical [ __ ] somehow swings
it back around to make you feel
something cliche now is the time for
action sure launching the bodies out
into space gives us an idea of the
devastation evil more to conflict but it
makes a little sense in terms of
disposal especially when you've already
shown us the giant garbage portal that
seems much more suited to the job still
not curious about what might have
happened at that crazy citadel place not
at all morty that place will never have
any bearing over our lives ever again
writers let the audience know that
nothing in the show is sacred and
they'll do whatever they please whenever
they want and that includes bringing the
citadel back probably somewhere around
the 500th season
oh geez rick oh jeez jeez oh geez oh man
oh geez hey oh geez man i hear that oh
geez but uh jeez oh geez man oh geez
come on
oh geez rick oh man oh jeez
rick and morty run away from the edward
without scissor hands towards the stairs
but then somehow wind up on these set of
stairs instead of the ones on the
original trajectory this could be
possible of course but the show doesn't
animate them jumping or rocketing over
there which would have been a lot of fun
to see also is this alien planet just
randomly heard of mcs sure do they just
have their own mcesher i'm gonna need to
walk up a few more impossible staircases
to figure this one out
well that's what you get for building
your escher palace over a space vortex
morty let's watch some interdimensional
cable remember how we used to do that i
do and if you want to remember i will
show you these two examples of videos
you could watch that do not benefit me
in any way i'm just looking out for you
i can't go on i i can't go on like this
with the truth tortoise in my head i was
just thinking this the last time i let a
tortoise [ __ ] on my head wait this morty
is my archive of all the experiences
you've begged me to remove from your
life lest you go insane i call them
mortys mind blowers seems like an
impressive amount when you see them all
but how many of them are just simply
about morty for getting the mind blowers
room exists because rick would have to
erase that memory every time as well
right also morty's memory manipulation
would be more accurate but rick is
taking the marketing approach here to
keep this intriguing like calling botox
a rejuvenating enhancement rather than
paralyzing injection jabs or a piece of
house a unique canvas ready for creative
solutions this labeling system that
appears to depend on the stickiness of
the tape certainly rick has the ability
to do better than this
okay so rick doesn't give a [ __ ] but why
then label it all i've never seen signs
of a regular dude as you describe him
hanging out up there but rick does have
the technology to take the memory from
morty at this point so why not looking
at morty's memory and see what he did to
confirm the person on the moon or tease
morty endlessly for the rest of his life
putting brown gravy on mashed potatoes
or really just putting brown gravy on
anything morty's at least 11 or 12 right
why are they still learning simple math
like 18 plus 10 at his age morty took a
picture in printable clarity at night
wait morty printed pictures for proof
this is insane who prints pictures oh my
god what have i done how did this memory
not convince morty that he'd actually
seen a man on the moon his memory is
clear at the beginning and this is
obviously a man and not a smudge also
this is the same flag on the moon as in
the yard there is no other conclusion to
draw from this memory except morty was
correct about the man on the moon they
don't all have titles though it's not a
simpsons halloween special more like a
clip show made of clips you never saw
these are clips that morty never saw
these are clips that morty can't
remember but he definitely saw them at
some point or they wouldn't exist the
collector comes to peek into their
habitat and spots rick disassembling a
television wouldn't this be somewhat
alarming why would the collector allow
the specimens to take apart their
environment oh the schematics specify a
second smaller pilot i mean they really
specify smaller they have to be exactly
five foot three but why morty normally
just sits in normal sized seats what
would his height have to do with
anything in regards to the schematics
and rick's making it pretty obvious
these idiots are being set up to be
stuck in an alien human zoo how come i
was able to see those other people's
memories i i wouldn't have been around
for that morty would be nootropic at tv
sins this very confusing piece of paper
that came from an alien but is written
in english now maybe the paper is
designed to translate to be legible to
whoever reads it but then why wouldn't
it be written properly with the name
capitalized in a period after warrior
having two glasses of whatever this is
while also having a glass of whatever
this is is that orange juice oh great
now i'm thinking about oj with mexican
food and you can take that flavor combo
straight to hell rick and morty i'm
gonna go take a quick sh so rick goes to
the bathroom and walks away down the
hallway i thought that was odd because i
assumed the bathroom doors were here
then the shot cuts to floop and over his
shoulder the sign says the bathrooms are
the opposite direction from where rick
went however on the wide shot the arrow
is pointed in the other direction and
we're left with nothing but assumptions
about where rick actually went to take a
sh honestly this is probably the most
haunting part of the episode all right
so you want to do this here or outside
i'm not privy to all the donkuco
establishment rules but i'm going to go
out on a limb and assume they don't
approve of alien murder in their
restaurant during normal operation hours
in the meantime enjoy a grab bag of mind
blowers i call poop aids underscore copy
and by grab bag he means two two scenes
does not a grab bag make you simply have
to choose summer
summer okay go with me here sure beth
had that answer at the ready far too
quickly but really the blame is on this
alien for not creating a soundproof
torture bubble grandpa rick there must
be some scientific way to save him the
visuals are saying wind the audio is
saying wind but the lack of wind in
anyone's hair other than morty is saying
continuity issue well i guess it's nice
to know the whole family sucks it took
you almost three seasons to realize that
rick opens the door panel by hitting it
with his fist but doesn't he know the
shooting door panels is the official way
to make sci-fi doors open for the fun of
the show these two have just wiped
almost all of their memories but all
indication is that the mind wiper would
only wipe one specific memory and not an
identity see those two fleshy sacks
under his chin morty
grab him not specifying which of the six
fleshy sacks you're talking about we're
partners i guess and we fight aliens
like men in black morty can't remember
who he is but he conveniently remembers
the movie men in black where one of the
main plot lines was about a device that
could wipe out people's memories
scooping up a potentially compromised
memory tube from the broken pile on the
floor rather than selecting one of the
many pristine tubes from the nearby
shelves leaving your interstellar
laboratory garage door wide open
this audible beep would give rick all
the indicators he needs to know that the
machine is being accessed by morty
there's no way he wouldn't hear it and
try to stop him from ruining whatever
morty is inevitably about to ruin there
i'm done just stay out of trouble
believing this would work
what's the point of going on if most of
everything that happens just
ends up sitting in here my thoughts on
cloud storage somehow make their way
into this episode you guys doing morty's
mind blowers asks the ice pop eating
sister who conveniently wanders into the
garage and enters the bunker only
seconds before her family ends the
episode with a bang which is almost as
convenient as some are also wearing a
key necklace needed to access the panel
that will save rick and morty i'm saying
this is too convenient and rick morty
should be dead
there is no way she consumed each of the
steps on that card that quickly and you
should never do step number one without
reading all the remaining steps to
ensure there's no [ __ ] regarding step
number one in the following steps
especially when step one requires you to
shoot people also making me say steps
too many times no wonder you're
constantly fighting with each other and
behind schedule that's a funny way of
saying i should have just kept your
memories wiped because you're both
[ __ ] stop true crime bragging
comment section of my favorite murder
episode somehow makes its way into the
show
my generation gets traumatized for
breakfast kids was it my best work i
don't know does it deserve to be [ __ ] on
creatively instead of acknowledging how
childhood memories can be inaccurate
rick gets all defensive as if beth just
dropped in everything wrong with
froopyland video this calendar with only
four days in the week you know it
collapsed a quantum tesseract adding the
word quantum to no wait adding the word
tesseract to no that's not it either
okay got it combining two sciency words
and adding a random verb to create a
phrase that sounds like rick did
something impressive cliche drawing a
portal on a mobile door based on the
trees alone it's pretty obvious that
rick ripped off dr seuss and no one gets
away with that without a synonym dad
you're right i'm a terrible dad the
terrible dad then goes on to throw
himself from the cliff that won't kill
him rather than pushing his unsuspecting
daughter to her non-death and that would
have really sealed the terrible dad
title into place for eternity a dad
makes a toilet look like r2d2 and it
breaks the front page of reddit
insinuating that rick gives a star wars
size about the front page of reddit
seriously this hurts really bad in that
case you'd think he wouldn't wait until
being taken to the nest to take out his
gun and shoot threat no people saw these
two people floating in people-sized
bubbles and stopped to take a picture
and or follow for the views of the
people they would surely garner on
social media your place looks way less
like a crack house show doesn't clarify
if this assessment is based on
first-hand experience at a crack house
or some are making assumptions based on
tv or some [ __ ] it's actually clean like
a cocaine house joe doesn't clarify if
this assessment is based on first-hand
experience at a cocaine house or morty
making assumptions based on tv or some
[ __ ] i'm simply centered activated
writers make summer suddenly clumsy as
if jerry isn't annoying enough to show
off his powers without provocation who
wants a smoothie first off no one said
yes and second anyone that does want a
smoothie would also like you to put a
little more effort into the recipe and
not just put every piece of rinded fruit
you have into a blender also summer and
morty both just stand there and watch
jerry not putting the top back on the
blender without screaming running or
voicing disapproval in any way
whatsoever i'm sure you noticed what she
has three of but guess what she has two
of is a thing that jerry just said to
his children are you seeing tommy
survived here by having sex with fruity
creatures creating fruity human hybrid
offspring and then consuming their
proteins sustaining himself with an
endless cycle of cannibalistic incest
writers suddenly realize their stories
the hair too long and complicated for
the show's 20-something minute run time
so they ham fist the episode with a
bunch of quick-witted exposition wrapped
in a plot reveal so disgusting we feel
the need to go wash our hands during the
commercial break dad do you understand
how serious crew tabulon soul bonding is
nope and considering it doesn't come up
for the remainder of the episode it's
probably not that big of a deal at all
she's got a hot bod like chitara in
thundercats if the thundercats exist in
this cartoon universe would they be
considered cartoons or by the standards
of their reality would they be
considered live action and if a cartoon
universe has its own version of cartoons
wouldn't those cartoons have to be
one-dimensional and what would that even
look like these are the kind of answers
i watch rick and morty for and i'm not
getting them after all the time and
energy i spent teaching you two about
race he ended up racist the sin is the
writers thinking jerry would think that
he could get away with pretending to
think that he could have possibly taught
anyone anything i always find the
theater is the best way to clarify
things somewhere in time there's a fifth
grade version of me watching a
performance of the crucible that would
very much disagree do you want to see
the honey swamp the same wreck that made
the ground bouncy and the water
breathable managed to overlook the fact
that a swamp filled with honey is many
orders of magnitude more dangerous than
a regular swamp i am hungry and all i
could do to pass the time is hump my
dog's inner monologue somehow makes its
way into the episode leave them alone
gather round gang dinner touch moments
after tommy has applied his seed this
animal births a new fruity character and
unfortunately the rules of this episode
place this sin in the category of meals
being prepared too quickly to have been
made in accordance with proper food
safety measures all right that's it i'm
out of here no one untied rick's hands
he just slipped out of them to escape so
why not do this before watching the
theatric retelling of tommy's
cringe-worthy survival plan but tommy's
still in there ripping muppets and
eating babies here's the thing that beth
said in this episode look at some of the
[ __ ] you were asking me to make you as a
kid ray guns do they shoot rays or are
they named rey or do they specifically
shoot only people named ray hey these
are legitimate questions for a show
that's willing to introduce a sentient
switchblade a lightning gun that's just
a fancy taser a teaser shaped like a
ladybug that's just a fancy lightning
gun a pink sentient switchblade does it
being pink make it worse then why didn't
you specify the colors of the other
objects hmm rick and why hasn't rick
fixed his boo-boos has it occurred to
you that i asked you to make those
things because i wanted you to spend
time with me has it occurred to you that
your request for these items resulted in
a father that actually made them thereby
encouraging your behavior take that to
your next counseling session i i i think
you have to stab them through the heart
or something says the guy stabbing the
creature through the head so if the
alien heart is the head then morty
should share that specific information
with his family to avoid confusion
people should eat people they should not
and that's why one [ __ ] plus two
[ __ ] makes a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch
at most this is a clowder and you know
it look i'm not an evil person i'm just
not very imaginative but doesn't it take
imagination to create the lie that your
children were responsible for the
breakup i know jerry makes no sense but
the writing of jerry not making sense
should make sense make sense this
calendar with only five days in the week
we wouldn't dare play the music in the
background of this touching
father-daughter working moment mostly
because song about taking a shirt in the
show is trying to make us think it's a
metaphor for fatherhood do they have
this t-shirt just laying around or did
they spend time making this because it's
not easy writing on t-shirts it takes a
lot of time to get the lettering right
so this feels a bit like they wasted
time on this instead of rushing to stop
the execution having more fridge
pictures of a child that you do not
prefer none of the varrics chose this
moment of distraction to attack the
warrior women who slaughtered their kin
yesterday you just got handed an ex
machina cliche
we're home leaving the front door wide
the [ __ ] open arnaldo's isn't closed in
the dimension where they didn't invent
daylight savings what would we do
without you find a pizza place that
doesn't close before dinner time or at
least not before the sun goes down by
the way that wasn't time travel there
were just a couple pizzas on the counter
i grabbed them rick has to break the
fourth wall to explain something so the
internet doesn't explode with fan
theories about what the insipid detail
of rick not waiting for pizza means in
regard to what is and is impossible yo
jerry it's the big r uh i killed that
alien that was coming after you looking
out for you buddy sho thinks we would
momentarily believe that rick did
something nice for jerry and not see the
nobody really uses those anymore except
for exposition on tv shows anyways show
cleverly writes its way out of an
antiquated joke by expositing its own
exposition but still exposition the
social violation of an elevator that
starts moving before the doors close
also discount daniel day-lewis
if they can teleport why did we take
this work here steve same as you look
sometimes the characters in rick and
morty practically write these videos for
me which actually makes my job harder
because i have to get extra nitpicky to
justify my existence like pointing out
that this mail slot was not in the
establishing shot of the house that we
saw just a few seconds ago and nobody
likes it when i have to do that rick do
you need to drink in here yes not to
disregard the obvious alcoholism on
display here but the martini glass is
the most spillable adult beverage
container ever conceived there's been no
attempt at displaying any sort of
technology that would allow rick to fall
vertically through a portal without
spilling his drink some kind of alien
googa has infested the kennedy sex
tunnels the president concludes that it
must be alien guga without testing for
chlamydia first yeah that sounds fun
let's set some boundaries with a spoiled
control freak that thinks he runs the
world and orders drone strikes to cope
with his insecurity or some people call
it being a parent okay you're not gonna
have fun if you analyze everything morty
underestimates how much i enjoy my job
as far as he knows we're still in the
tunnels when should we reveal we can see
them show expects me to believe that
rick wouldn't immediately know that
there was a satellite spying on them or
that he wouldn't have some sort of
countermeasure in place that would blow
it up turn it into pudding or evolve it
into an ai capable of explaining that
building a spy satellite and getting it
into orbit is a huge waste of money when
everyone has a cell phone in their
pocket i mean what doesn't look bad
through an illegal spy satellite and ice
cream and yes yes yes yes you save the
world now and then and america returns
that favor by not holding the two of you
accountable to its laws any of them any
of the laws okay i can see why turning a
blind eye to some laws would be
necessary when dealing with giant heads
that kidnap the planet and other
assorted nuisances but all laws you're
telling me they could go to arizona
purchase a donkey and let it sleep in a
bathtub with no consequences the
production team makes a banger of a song
for a five second joke but has the
audacity to not make the banger of an
album we all pause the episode to search
for just promise if the results are too
strong you'll use protection by results
you mean summer's choice right right how
do you like that morty the absence of
torches here makes me question why this
scene does not contain a rick and morty
getting blown up by a [ __ ] creeper
that apparated out of nowhere causing
them to lose over 1 000 levels of xp
farming and that damn nephrite sword
that they were saving for just the right
occasion followed of course by having to
work their way back from who the knows
where to assess the damage and pray to
the ender dragon that their carefully
plotted cave system has not been flooded
or filled with lava or you know
something less specific south park did
it four years ago morty they're fast or
we're slow me every time i carefully
craft my own version of a meme that i
saw while eating breakfast only to
discover it has somehow become a thing
enjoyed being a thing and is now no
longer a thing before my coffee is hit
room temperature also south park did
that episode about the simpsons already
doing all the things and how it doesn't
matter so i don't really have an excuse
for not making the meme and the writers
don't have an excuse for not giving us a
minecraft episode the only way using
this portal makes sense is if it's a
quicker option than the president just
flying there this means the portal would
have to already be there or at least be
closer than the president is but why why
would it be stationed in brazil do they
have one of these things in every
country aren't they super expensive and
why am i surprised that the government
has the ability to waste my money i made
sanchezium up dumbasses don't believe
everything you read on wikipedia well
[ __ ] excuse me while i go and review
several hundred of our videos for
reasons
i don't doubt a bar like this exists
somewhere in the multiverse but wouldn't
it make more sense for the footwear on
the torkasaurus sex to go all the way up
to the
heel inverted secondary knee whatever it
is this current setup does not look
twerkable what does
what what does this mean this means
nothing just pull forward and park
[Laughter]
even with all the sci-fi hijinks in this
episode somehow the show finds a way to
make one of the funniest moments out of
a simple frustration caused by
miscommunication thank you to everyone
involved and especially keith david for
bringing this hilarious character to
life
israel and palestine have announced a
permanent ceasefire what they signed
something called the pretty obvious if
you think about it accord rick proving
he could do more to help mankind in an
afternoon than anyone else could do in
10 lifetimes but he'd rather dick around
in his garage cliche an anonymous
american diplomat took them to a star
wars cantina where they smoked
perspective-enhancing alien pheromones
through a laser hookah i see no laser i
demand a laser hookah oh and peace in
the middle east that too your approval
rating just hit 100 it is literally not
figuratively literally impossible for a
president to get 100 approval rating
everyone could be rich healthy and never
exposed to war and some [ __ ] would
still say they have the right to be
homeless unhealthy and at risk of high
velocity lead poisoning i was knocking
out a deterrent everyone wants to be
knocked out nobody wants to be dead zack
snyder explaining why his version of
batman kills bad guys instead of
subduing them somehow makes its way into
the episode doctor who and his mother
proclamations of being the doctor do not
make you the doctor and among other
things rick is approaching this
situation much more like a dalek i'd
love to understand how i can help you i
can't be in charge of that jerry my mind
my ideas are all part of the variable
the only constant is you this plan only
works if beth is correct in thinking
that there's some ineffable quality
inside all of us that no clone no matter
how perfect could ever fully replicate
and while you all sit there insisting
you would definitely know the difference
if your loved ones were replaced with
clones i'll be chatting to the ai that
built the simulation we live in senior
year i took you on a date skip and i
just thought lips don't sweat lips may
not sweat but the face around those lips
does sweat a fact that turned out to be
a deal breaker for
my freshman year episode makes a weird
metaphor about destroying conspiracy
surrounding the apollo moon landing the
kennedy assassination in 9 11. at least
i hope that's what they were going for
and we're hiding from you so you don't
kill her if she's a clone in a place i
pick that you will never find i think
morty is fastly underestimating rick's
ability to track i'm sure he has ways of
scanning for morty's dna or an army of
drones that scout the entire planet in
minutes or maybe he could just track the
[ __ ] cell phone that morty's decided
to keep you're a terrorist you're an
enemy of the state and you kicked me in
the balls 10 minutes ago oh and all
those secret service people he killed
earlier but no need to bring that up i
suppose invisit troopers stand down why
are invisitroopers with knives
preferable to invisi troopers with
lasers i hope i could be of service if
uh you ever find the planet to be in
danger friends
sounds good to me the president thinks
he's making a deal with a rick from
another universe but what makes him
think that fly fishing rick would be any
better than regular rick he could be
just as murdery and insubordinate but
with the added annoyance of being one of
those people with a passion for
something hopefully you didn't just [ __ ]
around and waste your life
making us think mr poopy butthole is
going to be a fun call back then
tricking us into reflecting on all our
poor life decisions
pickle juice tastes like garbage it
sucks
he may have manifested some sort of butt
allow me to share with you a motto i
believed and throughout my life nobody
who is an ass man can be all bad
maybe i just want you to care if i run
away yelling it was just like sonny said
it would be
nobody cares so if you really want your
grandpa back grab a shovel the one that
won't let you down is buried in your
backyard
welcome to mcdonald's can i take your
order i'll have two number nines
a number nine large
a number six with extra dip
a number seven
two number 45s one with cheese and a
large soap
it's my vagina
then the universe exploded into
existence and the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots
infinity stone
it's because losers look stuff up while
the rest of us are carbonyl them dms
belief
like fear or love
is a force to be understood as we
understand the theory of relativity and
principles of uncertainty kill me please
i won't kill you but i don't have to
save you how come you guys dress like
you're in a theme park stunt show but
these guys wear khakis and hockey
jerseys this is the way after the boom
boom some adapted to the new truth you
speak the true truth and he wants more
and the hulkster's giving them exactly
what they want i'll be right back
deathstalkers bring me his flesh leather
sorry my grandpa stole your god and
ruined your car you don't turn your back
on family
even when they do
i am summer summer state your deal you
already know my name and you can see
that i'm a machine i don't know why i'm
crying why are you crying there's no
crying
you know is this the first part of some
kind of magic trick illusion michael hmm
trick is something a horde does for
money god damn it i love myself because
i love me and me
dad
i would like you to tell me what's in
the syringe
around and give it a shot come on
i'm a pickle
when i feel like it so you asked well
actually nobody on this planet ever
really chooses each other i mean it's
all a question of quantum physics
molecular attraction and timing it's
maximus renegade star soldier
that man is playing galaga thought we
wouldn't notice but we did there's a
classic case of
guy on the ground
obviously i came here last night during
a blackout
man
so this is what the zone feels like oh
analyze this vance stay calm wake up you
made a deal with a force that's bigger
than you when the time comes they're
gonna ask you to pay what they feel you
owe them it's for the greater good
surprise [ __ ] i'm gonna lay my
head gently on your shoulder
maybe we can cry hug
maybe even slow dance don't patronize me
dean dangerous
[Music]
a sacrifice of blood mean would be
shooting you jerry this is saving a
bullet do you comprehend the value of
the bullet in your barrel i tell you
fellas this is the life robe
let's go in and out 20 minutes adventure
four to six days later
hey uh you mind if i put on some music
not at all
the bird is a word
hey morty remember yesterday when i
couldn't play the trombone well check
this out
[Music]
not quite my temple what's a knockout
like you doing in a computer-generated
gin joint like this
i'm out of my awkward state
john one thing i can promise you even in
this market is that i never ask my
clients to judge me on my winners i
asked them to judge me on my losers
because i have so few uh yeah i think we
actually have the audio for his speech
here i just got a free churro because my
mom died the elections got these yellow
shirts more riled up than a picture day
jessica if you're gonna get nasty i'm
gonna leave
yes slow rick tall morty i said
reading is good
can we start the story now
see all you fresh-faced kidlets sitting
there in your neat little rose
and you're all just pods
pods waiting for your instructions
from the ricks and mortys that believe
in this citadel
to the ricks and mortys that don't
you're screwed thank you bye
what's this
the spice menage
they say for your wish to come true you
have to give up something really
important yeah
but you know what
this one
this one right here
this was my dream my wish
and it didn't come true
this is the story of a boy with scissors
for hands
return the truth tortos
you have no power over me
what the hell is this a center for ants
you want thingamabobs
i got 20.
[Music]
but i do have a thing oh god do i have
to keep looking then grab boys don't
kill him i will who wants a smoothie
what are you talking about a smooth like
a drink or something listen i've been
giving you a pass because i'm charmed
that life finds a way but there's one
thing the history of evolution has
taught us that life will not be
contained life breaks free it expands to
new territories and it crashes through
barriers painfully maybe even
dangerously but
uh
well there it is well here's the problem
right here a mutated p-36
immunosuppression gene that renders them
immune to all poisons
what is that smell
it's poo poo with a dashikako i suppose
you're wondering how do i sustain myself
i am evil therefore i am lonely
well that didn't go as planned
i respect your right to believe i pushed
you when you marooned me on that
godforsaken spit of land you forgot one
very important thing mate
i'm captain jack sparrow
i roared
and i rampaged
and i got bloody satisfaction
tell him rick and morty just blew off
america hey phrasing yes yes yes yes you
saved the world now and then and america
returns that favor by not holding the
two of you accountable to its laws
diplomatic community
wouldn't go well
can you elaborate because of the
implication
what a rush
do you even know how to take out this
kind of threat you don't like my plan
that's good give me another plan but
don't tell me we're backing out doctor
who and this [ __ ] i have the
power of a thousand cowboys running
through my veins right now